[Music]
william yuri is one of the nicest people
i have ever met
whenever i talk to him i feel at ease i
feel like i'm learning i feel like i can
accomplish anything
and this is probably not by accident
he is best known for being the co-author
of getting to yes which is a staple for
any business school student or quite
frankly most people in the world it's
sold an astonishing
15 million copies and been translated a
whole bunch of languages
he also co-founded the program on
negotiation for harvard law school
he's been negotiating peace agreements
around the world for decades from
nuclear disarmament pacts with the
soviet union
to arab-israeli conflict to tribal
squabbles among the bushmen of the
kalahari so i thought i'd call him to
see if he could shed some light on how
we can resolve some of the many
conflicts that we have ongoing in our
world today
this
is a bit of optimism
you have made a career not only as a as
an author and professor but a peace
negotiator you've traveled around the
world whether it's arabs and israelis or
venezuela or wherever you've gone
to negotiate peace amongst people who
hate each other let's be honest
it seems that's what we need in our
country
that we have two factions
and i believe it's more political
parties than it is the average
population i don't i think we're still
pretty moderate and i think america is
pretty frustrated with the state of the
world but we have two parties of a
single nation that accuse each other of
being traitors or un-american there's no
listening there's only talking so my
question is is
have you ever negotiated peace
inside a reasonably functional country
inside a reasonably functional
government like how do we get peace in
this country bill great questions you
know it's funny it's ironic because you
know i've been wandering the world for
the last
four decades looking for the most
intractable conflicts and i come back
and i find
an intractable conflict an impossible
conflict right here in my own country
which has a lot of the same features of
the arab israeli conflict or the
conflict in venezuela that's been
roiling that country for 20 years
we're dividing ourselves
into two different tribes that
and there's
i agree with you that i still think the
majority of americans
who don't dominate the airwaves
you know basically we want to get along
with each other we're dividing ourselves
with these two tribes of democrats and
republicans
and hating each other and
forgetting that
way before were democrats and
republicans were americans you know and
what do americans do americans talk you
know we meet we unite that's why we're
the united states and so
the question is how do we do that when
we've been hijacked i mean essentially
that's how i think of it our country's
been hijacked even in the brain you know
there's this left amygdala that was
there to protect us but is driven by
fear and our left amygdala has been
hijacked and
we're trying to protect what we hold
dear from those enemies the result is
that by playing this finite game as you
would put it you know a win-lose game
the result is we're all losing and we're
losing our country and so the question
is how do we get out of it i believe we
can do it because i've seen it happen in
other countries where it's been worse
you know i was in south africa during
apartheid i mean apartheid was 10 times
worse than what's here in this country
in terms of hatred bloodshed and racism
and everyone thought when i was there in
the 80s you know people thought this is
this blood war is going to go on for as
long as we can tell you know even the
best observers and yet within a very few
brief years
the south africans proved them wrong and
they transformed their country they
didn't end their conflict but they
transformed it and apartheid came to an
end and if they could do it we can do it
you said the conflict here between
these two warring factions of political
parties
mimics some of the elements of
arab-israeli conflict can you
break down more specifically what are
the common elements that you see well
one is
toxic emotions
treating the other with contempt when we
get into that reactive deep fear of the
other almost existential fear that our
very life you know is in danger from the
other side from the enemy that's what's
present in the arab israeli conflict and
increasingly present here number two is
the positions
get really entrenched and there's no
budging i mean there's no communication
it's like your different realities were
in different silos you know and that
that you find true in the arab israeli
conflict too
and the third is
the intensity of the fighting where it's
almost on the verge of violence or at
times it leaks into violence and there's
even you know vast numbers of americans
fear that we're headed towards a civil
war where there would be levels of
violence unprecedented here in this
country since the civil war
those are the three elements that are
common to the arab-israeli conflict it's
the toxic emotions the rigidly opposed
positions that don't budge and the
intensity the fighting the fierce
fighting and i can't help but point out
that the arab-israeli conflict is still
ongoing
[Laughter]
so i want to talk about solutions
obviously
but i i feel it's important to try and
understand how we got here in the first
place
what is it that takes
a nation where people were cooperative
and did get along and politics
was
not always like this
how did we get here in the first place
because it clearly didn't happen
overnight it's been a steady drumbeat
it's been an evolution to get from that
to this do we need to understand the
route before we can really solve the
problem i think it's really important to
to go to the balcony for me which is
that metaphor yeah a place where we can
get the larger picture and that's what's
really needed here when you're hijacked
you need to go to that balcony which is
the the right thinking part of the brain
the prefrontal cortex and there are
different factors that have created this
you know there was the loss of a common
enemy you know these in our lifetimes
you know we have the soviet union but i
think more importantly in this country
there were
large segments of people who felt left
behind
when i started off in the field of
conflict resolution negotiation i was
looking around for where i could really
get my hands dirty i just doesn't want
to read about in books so i took a job
as a mediator in a coal mine in kentucky
i did my doctoral research as
anthropologists in that coal mine and i
got to know the people and it's those
people who feel left behind and those
people to whom trump spoke and continues
to speak but people who feel like their
country is being taken away from them
underneath and when you have a
substantial number of people who feel
excluded and that's not even to speak of
people other people i mean obviously
americans have felt left behind you know
so many different groups but when you
exclude people and when people feel
excluded and humiliated then you start
to go into your different tribes and
then of course there's the effect of
social media that creates cocoons and
different realities there are a lot of
different factors that have created this
problem and it's really important to
understand them if we're going to figure
out how we're going to get through this
and i believe
based on my experience and i have to
tell you you know after all these years
of working in the world's impossible
conflicts
i haven't given up hope for this country
i believe it's possible because i've
seen it happen in other situations with
my own eyes and i believe we can still
do it so existential threat an external
existential threat i think is very
interesting when the soviet union fell
out of the game
we as a population no longer perceive
this external existential threat
and something history has shown us this
upsets me this depresses me but i in all
of my work it seems to be clear that
one of the ways in which human beings
find clarity and what they stand for
is not by
articulating their why
but by looking for the thing that is the
opposite of what they stand for because
knowing what we stand for can sometimes
be ethereal and intangible and about the
future and something like that where
when i can see and feel
a threat to the thing that i believe and
though i can't put it into words
that's tangible
and when the soviet union fell away the
thing that was the not that you know we
i don't know what i stand for but i know
it's not that
we start looking for a not that anywhere
to help give us a sense of purpose or
cause and unfortunately when we no
longer look outwards we start looking
inwards
so it upsets me as a as an idealist
that that we have to have an enemy to
know what we stand for but it seems
that that is the case and unfortunately
we have ignored
any threats from the outside world and
are focused exclusively on the
false enemy within that's true we've met
the enemy and they are us the thing is
when we get hijacked by fear
then we look for a scapegoat you project
all of the
problems that all of the
terrible things you projected on someone
and then you try to kill them in some
way or and that's a path to doom for us
because
we live in a highly interdependent world
we live
as you put it an infinite game you know
we live in a world of relationships and
when you take that very narrow
win-lose
us versus them mentality
and you put it in a world that's as
complex and interdependent and
relational as we are
you may get short-term wins but the
truth is in the end everybody loses you
get lose lose lose outcomes and we can
see that happening in our country that
even the winners lose i mean you know
like the democrats won but for how long
and they're going to lose and then you
know then the republicans win and then
they lose but the truth is the whole
country is losing through the battle
yeah i see only one way out which is we
need to change we need a paradigmatic
shift in the way we look at conflict
we've forgotten it's not enough just to
go from win-lose to win-win that doesn't
work anymore there is a third win that
we've missed which is a win for us all
you know win for the community a win for
the society what both sides think
they're doing is that but they're
defining community as their base yes and
so i have to defend the values of my
side before they
destroy this country you got it when i
was in apartheid looking at south africa
in the 80s i also spent some time with a
group of hunter gatherers always the
anthropologist right
i was interested how did we survive
because we lived as hunter-gatherers our
minds everything is like you know 99
more than that of our time has been as
hammers and gatherers and
the secret i found that they have is
very simple when there's a fight you
know between two individuals or two
groups what happens is the whole
community gathers around the campfire
women men everybody the parties and they
look into that fire which is the fire of
conflict and they talk and they talk
past each other and they listen and they
argue whatever and it goes on for days
and at night they call out to the
spirits for help and guidance and then
they don't rest until not just the
conflict is resolved the issue is
resolved but there has to be a
reconciliation and sometimes tempers are
much too high and so the elders suggest
you know you go out and you know to one
of the parties you go and visit some
relatives for about six months you know
cooling off but the key is
there's a shift in mindset because we
approach every conflict like it's got
two sides in this case you know it's
democrats versus the republicans
vaccines versus anti-vaxxers you this
versus that what they know is that
there's always a third side
and the third side is not the neutrals
in between it's the whole community that
takes responsibility and has that
campfire and that's how i figured we
survived as a species and to me that's
what we need to look for today in
today's america is we need to remember
to take the third side we need to
remember that we're americans before
we're democrats and republicans there's
one little detail that makes that
argument fall apart which is remembering
that we're americans but that's the
problem which is you know each side
believes that they are the most american
americans yeah and the other side is
violating the sanctity of what it means
to be american and so you're back at
square one but you talk about something
i think that needs to be we need to go
deeper on in each case you talk about
relationship coming together all of this
stuff
and there was a profound
shift in the united states government
that happened back in 1994 which
has to be talked about
which is it used to be that when
somebody won a position in federal
office
they
moved their family to washington dc and
they lived in washington dc
and though they fought
during the day
at their job
in the evenings they went to the pta
meetings
and they went to the kids baseball games
and they sat in the bleachers with
people from the opposite party and they
knew each other not as political foes
they knew each other as parents and
friends and they knew each other as
human beings
and then in 1994
one of the proposals that newt gingrich
made was
do not move your family to washington
that is a terrible thing to do you
should stay back and be with your
constituents and so politicians come in
for two or three days a week
do their business then go back and
they're not actually with their
constituents they're predominantly
fundraising so it's the whole thing's
folly
however the problem is none of them know
each other as parents or coaches or
friends they don't break bread together
so all of the the examples you give
there's a relational component we live
together we hang out together our kids
are friends and that no longer exists in
washington dc and the question i raise
is can we ever have peace in america
if our politicians do not make friends
with each other i completely agree with
you i mean early on i remember 30-40
years ago we talked about the importance
of what are called cross-cutting
linkages and that's what you're talking
about those little league games where
you cut you cross
your ideological lines you cross your
religious lines you cross everything and
america has thrived on forging those
cross-cutting linkages whether it's
rotary club or whatever it is you know
that brings people together
what's happened is
there's been this fraying of that and we
do need to reverse that and i'll just
give you as an example just you know
back to
uh south africa apartheid what they did
was because the fighting the violence
actually was so fierce
they formed what they called the
national peace accord which was they had
committees
at the neighborhood level where you
would have people of all races people of
all classes sitting around trying to
figure out how do we stop the violence
in our community working with the police
and so on and they had at a community
level
at the district level at the at the
state level and at the national level
the nosfora where people got together
across their differences for a common
goal which was
stopping the political violence so that
a shift could take place
that's
what made it possible and we need to do
something of the same the most important
thing we can do is reach out to our
neighbors
and
find people who disagree with us
and it's not that you have to talk about
the conflict
just
make a relationship with them but we're
in a situation that seems so toxic that
simply talking to the other side you get
black bold i heard of a story of a of a
congressional spouse dinner there were
two wives who've known each other for 30
years because both their husbands have
been in office for you know who knows
how long and they sat next to each other
because they're friends
and both
of their husbands
were admonished
and told never let that happen again so
here's the question i have like arab
israeli not a great example even though
some elements are the same because
they're still fighting that hasn't been
resolved
south africa though there are some
elements not a great example because the
violence got so bad
and there was a force of personality in
nelson mandela
which
matters that forced truth and
reconciliation to happen january 6
apparently wasn't bad enough
that the whole country was in such shock
that we said we probably need to stop
this so the question that i have is are
we simply waiting for something so
atrocious to happen that both sides can
look at themselves and go okay this
can't happen again
or
do you have a specific example that you
worked on that actually looks more like
us
than south africa or arab israeli
because we don't have nelson mandela and
the violence hasn't got so extreme that
we've become shocked into
doing something i i don't i don't want
it to get there that's the problem even
the pandemic wasn't enough to bring to
bring our country together well let me
just say a couple things one is
let's make no mistake this is the
hardest work that human beings can do
you know it is hard work to sit down and
talk or listen to someone whom you
violently disagree with and you
disapprove of and all that no question
number two i'm struck by your story
about the two
congressional wives and you know i see
that in every conflict which is
fraternizing with the enemy is frowned
upon and sometimes worse i'm just
remembering take another conflict
northern ireland you know catholics and
protestants you know sectarian strife
you know when i started people said it's
impossible there's no way catholics and
protestants you know they drink this in
with their mother's milk it's been gone
for centuries it's never gonna stop
it changed and and this is the key is we
have this wrong idea that has to be
resolved and we all have to live in
peace and harmony it's not about that
it's not about resolving conflict it's
about transforming it and transforming
is very different transforming means
changing the form from yes you continue
the conflict but instead of the
destructive ways you use you use
constructive ways and that's what
democracy is right it's you know
conflict is not bad
and so to me what happened in south
africa is the conflict didn't get
resolved it got transformed what
happened between the united states and
the soviet union was it didn't get
resolved but it got transformed the risk
of nuclear war went down you know you
went to majoritarian democracy in south
africa and in every conflict it's about
transformation of the conflict which is
a more modest goal
and more in line with the way our
democracy was set up is actually the
world needs more conflict because
whenever you have injustice or you need
to make a change you need conflict but
the question is how do you deal with the
conflict do you deal with the conflict
destructively in ways that destroy the
common good or do you contend
and cooperate together in ways that
promote the common good and that's
that's the real question
and the last thing i'll say is i think
right now it's true that the situation
hasn't gotten
so bad that it's woken us up
but i had a really interesting
conversation about a year ago with newt
gingrich and i was introduced to him by
van jones you know and
you know there between van newt and
myself we could find some common ground
in terms of being concerned for our
country where we are in this process and
can we turn this around so
i i still believe it's possible and and
and it may be
you know that things have to get a
little worse before they get better i've
seen it happen
and what it takes is
it takes the activation of us you know
of us
two things i want to explore here so
must there not be the courage of
accountability i met him once also newt
gingrich a few years ago and i found him
to be very astute a student of
history
he was dismayed by the situation in
america but i also found him completely
unapologetic or at least completely
blind
to his role
in where we are today you know there's a
side of me that thinks that until one
party and it can come from either side
takes the risk the courage for
accountability said we are a part of the
problem without saying
and so are they
you got it
and neither party
individually or as a collective seems to
have the courage to say we are part of
the problem
and you and i both know
good luck with your marriage if you
operate in a way like our politicians
operate like i'm right and you're wrong
like good luck with your marriage if you
think you know compromise is a dirty
word good luck with your marriage if you
hold fast to your beliefs for 30 years
and never ever ever see any kind of
growth you know we have a country that's
now more accepting that gender can be
fluid but political views nope that's
black and white our views are fluid i
have views that are pretty liberal and
views that are pretty conservative and
it makes me
messy and i think everybody's political
views are messy are you sure and you and
i both know from
personal relationships friendships are
romantic or otherwise until one person
has the courage to say
honey i'm sorry
i screwed up
it just goes on and on and on bill yuri
fix it
you know
you know going back to marriage that
marriage analogy you know if you're
asking the question who's winning this
marriage
your marriage is in serious difficulty
and that's the only question we're
asking is who's winning you know it's
it's like
no
it's that's not the question to be
asking the question is how do we make
this country work how do we create the
place we want for our kids so when we
talk about who's winning this marriage
i'm thinking okay let's game that out to
how our politics is looking right where
one parent
wants to make an indelible mark on their
children so that their children will
live the life that they think is the way
to live a life which is different than
my spouse
you know and they're competing to have
an indelible mark on their children like
our parties are competing to have an
indelible mark on the country
if that couple existed we would
recommend they divorce
[Laughter]
that's true and the trouble is
you know
this country we can't divorce i mean
people keep on dreaming fantasizing
about divorcing but but the truth is
we're all intermingled i mean every
state is red and blue i live in a red
and blue state i mean yeah but not
because of gerrymandering you know
better than anybody we don't live in a
world where the electors choose their
candidates the candidates chose their
electors they've cut it up so their
districts are only router only blue
which again means they don't have to
have a political message to appeal to
both sides they only need a political
message to appeal to their side and and
so that's pretty insidious as well
yeah so is this going to be fixed in a
day
no can it be done
absolutely i've just i've seen it happen
in other places back in the late 90s
i was a facilitator at a bipartisan
congressional retreat there were 200
members of congress a hundred democrats
100 republicans and their spouses and we
all got together and we
they talked in this is right after the
clinton impeachment and everyone felt it
was toxic in washington at that point
and they said to me that they'd had more
conversation with a member of the
opposite party
in the two-hour train ride from
washington up to hershey pennsylvania
where the conference was than they had
in the previous four years but it was
interesting was once we got them into
groups
just talking about their lives
and talking about what was on their mind
there are a lot of decent good people in
these and
these so they're trapped in the system
too they have to have courage but we we
also have to have courage and it can
happen i mean you've seen it happen
we've all seen it happen we've all seen
turnarounds in families
in workplaces
in communities i've seen it happen in
countries it can happen here it really
can and it starts with us not just
blaming all the politicians either it's
systemic but it starts with nuts can you
talk more about northern ireland um so
northern ireland
catholics and protestants
everyone in their different tribes
anyone who talked to the other side was
branded a traitor just like you were
saying
and so where did it start
in one way it started with
mothers
of
sons who had been killed because it's
like when a catholic mother and a
protestant mother
they got together
to grieve their sons or their brothers
or whatever their husbands who'd been
lost in the troubles
they couldn't be attacked so easily
because they were so clearly
had borne the the highest pain of the
troubles
once that happened
they had the courage you know that that
courage that comes from that fierce
thing then they opened a little door for
their religious leaders you know
catholics and protestants who could you
know the priests and the ministers say
you know i'm not sure killing each other
is actually what jesus christ had in
mind and you know people could could
imagine that you know
then they opened the door for the
business people who could say i'm not
sure this is good for businesses you
know driving away any kind of
investments and jobs and whatever and
the last to open up and show courage
were the politicians so there was a
pattern where it starts with a small
group in that case it was mothers
to religious leaders to business to
politicians
and that was when the floodgates opened
and then then you could actually try to
knit
together
a solution that didn't end the conflict
but it ended the war the one
uncomfortable detail i think that is an
excellent
path and an excellent analogy for us the
one uncomfortable detail
is that
the situation had grown so violent that
it reached a breaking point where
mothers said enough and we
january 6 notwithstanding we have not
reached a point where the violence had
reached a po has reached a point in
america and i do not want to get to that
point
where mothers are fed up with their
children dying because of political
fighting
the case you're making is that change
starts at home
the case you're making is that uncle who
has different political views at you and
we've there's so much conversation about
this that has happened
at the thanksgiving table you know what
do you do with with
with political discourse and most
families either don't show up
or they just all agree not to talk
politics
but i think what we're talking about is
the skill set of how do we find
resolution at home how do we find
resolution in our relationships and our
friendships how do you create safe space
for that uncle or aunt to feel heard
which is very difficult
that's what i said it's the hardest work
you could do and
it's doable we know it it takes exactly
what you're saying it takes courage it
takes taking responsibility in marriage
as a saying you can either choose to be
right or you can choose to be happy but
you can't choose to be both you know
do we want a country that works or do we
want to be right that's our choice your
work and you've written multiple books
over the years
getting to yes
how long
when did that book come out
decades ago 40 years ago oh my god
40 years ago i mean
and it's still one of the top selling
negotiation books that has ever been
written i mean it is it is the textbook
what if you learned about negotiation
vis-a-vis
this current state
that you look back at what you wrote 40
years ago and you say my goodness that's
more relevant now than ever or
i would say it differently now i
wouldn't say it the same way you know
i've learned more i would slightly adapt
that
i hope i've learned a little more
i get abs you know it's sold over like
15 million copies and it continues to
sell just as well today as it did you
know 40 years ago so
it hit a vein which was
at that time the best sellers on the
list on negotiation went by the titles
looking out for number one
and winning by intimidation and getting
yes gotta propose the revolutionary idea
that you could negotiate
and both sides could benefit you know
so-called win-win and it works and it's
had the enormous success and win wins
become almost a cliche
my feeling looking back over 40 years as
i look at the tough
seemingly impossible conflicts that we
face today
is
getting yes didn't go far enough there's
two missing elements
that you need in these really tough
intractable conflicts like the one we've
been discussing that need to go together
with getting ds to make it work
uh getting to yes is work with the other
right it's kind of like how do we dance
together to in a difficult conflict to
try to get to a yes
the prior work which is what you've been
talking about
is work with ourselves we need to get to
yes with ourselves
and we need to have that courage we need
to face our own fears
we need to do that work with ourselves
around us and that to me
is what i call balcony work we need to
learn to take pause we need to learn to
ask ourselves what do we really want
here we need to go from the amygdala
hijack in our left amygdala which is
just driven by fear to our right
thinking and really think about what's
really important here what's the price
so that to me is absolutely critical if
we're going to get to yes can you give
some specific guidance
to us as individuals if change starts at
home
let's say i have a friend or a family
member where we are on completely
different sides of the political divide
we are emblematic of our national state
of affairs
professor william yuri
phd what do i
have to do if i wish to establish peace
with my family member what's the first
thing that i need to do can you give me
some specific advice please yes
starts with breathing
[Laughter]
remember to breathe breath it brings
oxygen to our brain so we can actually
think about what's important because we
get trapped in emotions like fear and
anger and it's natural but that's not
going to have you say what you'd want to
say to your kid or to your spouse you
know you're going to do it by taking a
breath taking a pause taking a break
not hitting the send all button but
heading the save as draft button you
know and and thinking about it going for
a walk doing a workout whatever you do
to go to the balcony everyone has their
favorite techniques have a coffee with a
friend but just
don't react right on the spot
and just take you know in this very
hurly-burly world just take a break take
a breather
and ask yourself
what's my why
you know what what do i re what's my
prize here what do i really want what
kind of family do i want what kind of
relationship do i want what what do i
really want here other than to prove
them wrong or to be right what's higher
than that what's more important being
right or getting what you want and
everyone wants to get what they want so
that's what we need to do and right now
in this world which is a highly reactive
world we're always just going to
reaction we need to find ways to press
the pause button i find this so
interesting that successful engagement
starts with disengagement
that's it it starts stopping it starts
with stopping which is you find yourself
becoming enraged and angry and to say to
that person i want to have this
conversation but i need to step away for
a little bit first you got it that's
that's the secret right there wow thomas
jefferson you know during the
constitutional convention he used to say
when angry count to 10 if very angry a
hundred that's what we need to do we
need to count to ten and then come back
and think about what's going to really
advance our interests one of the things
that i've learned about what makes a
successful relationship
is that when we fight
we fight to get to resolution not to be
right and the other person to be wrong
and that the other party can see and
feel
their partner the other party
working hard
in that debate to get to resolution and
so it naturally changes
the tactics that i would use or that she
would use
like wanting to understand something i
don't understand where in the past i'll
just say you're wrong or that doesn't
make sense and now i'll say something
like i don't understand can you say it
again to help me understand
because i'm trying to get to resolution
right and so
i love this idea of before you start
stop
right the first step of engagement is
disengagement the higher purpose here is
resolution i'm trying to get to
resolution and the thing in between
those two is what you just alluded to is
listening you know people think well i
listen but the question is
do you really listen to understand the
other do you listen putting yourselves
in their shoes understanding where
they're coming from without giving up
where you are but just for a moment
trying to understand where they're
coming from that's the key is listening
from within their frame of reference not
just what we often do is we just listen
from our frame of reference and then our
mind is saying i disagree with that
that's wrong that's wrong no that's
that's not the kind of listening we're
talking about it's very simple
it's not easy to do but it turns out to
be the key that negotiation is much more
about listening than it's about talking
i think the hubris that needs to be put
aside is that the other party is worthy
of engagement you know i've had this
conversation with both sides of the
political spectrum where they believe
the other side is stupid and the other
side isn't worth talking to
which i find
insanely ironic
why would i talk to them they're so
stupid they won't listen to me i'm like
are you listening to yourself
but there has to be a belief that the
other party's point of view even if you
find disagreeable
has value to be heard yeah it doesn't
mean it has value to be right you don't
have to agree with somebody to find
resolution you don't have to agree with
somebody to find peace
and i love this idea of transforming the
conflict rather than ending the conflict
and that's my big takeaway from this
conversation with you which is peace is
not the end of conflict no it's the
transformation of conflict that we may
deal with our disagreements in a
constructive manner rather than a
destructive manner but conflict is
perfectly normal and healthy it's it's
not normal and healthy we need more
conflict in this world i mean that's the
paradox is because so much has been
suppressed needs to surface but we need
to surface it within a container that in
which it can be cooked it could be
transformed it could be made something
that we can eat
and on that note may we both sit down
and have a piece of conflict pie
the sweetest pie there is good old
american pie
bill you've got my mind spitting
i am
forever an endlessly grateful to you
not just for coming and talking with me
but just for being you and being out in
the world fighting the good fight and
helping us learn how to live together
and get along together i absolutely love
you i love your work and i just love you
endlessly so thank you so so much this
is the best simon that love is mutual
and it's a huge pleasure to be your
friend ah thank you bill
[Music]
if you'd like to learn more about what
bill is doing and how you can help to
advance peace in the world
check out his organization
abrahamspath.org
if you enjoyed this podcast and would
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself
take care of each other